hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess.com
and going to track Magnus
Carlson early title Tuesday December
19th
2023 he's currently sitting at a
all-time high Blitz rating he broke his
record from a handful of days
ago
3363 Blitz rating so 11 rounds
of three +
one first round opponent National Master
good night
kiss okay starting with
G3 let's see a focus on D5 the first two
moves first three moves oh probably a
mouse slip not a good
[Laughter]
[Music]
start okay not the end of the world
world not
something you can't
undo or maybe he's just trying to be
creative I don't know probably a mouse
slip he'll try to justify this
somehow I wonder if he's going to duck
as soon as this pawn moves will he
decline the light Square Bishop exchange
or
not maybe he'll start positioning pawns
on light squares instead of D4 it is
D3 so maybe a light Square Bishop
exchange and then he plays E4 to
coordinate with his dark Square
Bishop big
moment to trade or not to trade followup
E4 negative so he's working on the H6
Square I guess Queen
D2 shooting for queenside expansion A3
B4 black is is there first
though okay with the queen on C8 E7 is a
bit
soft can't really take he lose defense
of E7 and also D6 in the
end okay so now we have a huge Square
here for the
Knight Superior minor piece
position I think ideally white would
like to have oh okay he's going with B4
the Knight is supporting that
ideally I think he'd like to have
another Knight exchange and just like
get these two guys
off and this this guy dominates also
Beware of the
fork Knight
E7 so he can't take like
that all
right it's going to be a problem here
pressure on it with the queen and then
the Rook I'm not sure how you save this
Pawn because again this Knight can't
move Knight B4 take with the
Rook Knight
E7 any knight move to the center you
take Knight
E7 counterattacking the Knight isn't
working Queen takes C5 defends the
Knight and threatens Queen takes Knight
with the followup
fork
okay threat here Queen takes
Knight I imagine Rook F to C8 yep and
from here where's the tactic
okay you could take there winning a
second Pawn
there no time to take here Rook takes
Rook maybe maybe you could maybe you
could because you are on F3 in the
end not sure what's happening after
Queen takes
E2 okay just nice and cozy defending the
Knight everything is co everything is
defended now
okay I wonder wait a second there was a
blunder there oh in the end there would
have been a fork if Queen takes
Knight King takes and then a followup
here forking the the queen and
Knight or the the uh queen and
king I think in the end though there was
Knight E7 getting the
Rook
okay we have a check another check and
then you get to take the bishop with
check I imagine a resigner everything is
coordinated
now a resigner here under 30 seconds for
team
black now he's going to play on a bit
more everything's covered no tricks here
he push the a pawn Knight F4 I don't
think this check is going anywhere this
seems
healthy base points are all covered
could even trade down into a brooken
pawn ending if you wanted
to oh he's calculated a mate I guess
Queen takes Rook we're going to see the
mate oh he was just doing that to be
flashy that's that's the showing him who
boss technique right there he's going to
mate with the pawn or a
knight there's only two squares to cover
or that one I didn't see that one coming
covers both of them in one swing I want
to go back
actually that was that was clearly a
case of you know I could repeat you got
nothing better but I want to go back to
this point
right right here so before he
played King
G2 if Queen takes Knight King takes and
then this
Fork gets out of the way he has seen
deeper because in the end there's that
one and you get the
Rook okay round one of 11 in the books
round two there's a bunch of uh one out
of ones as you would expect Hikaru sain
wonderful time Wesley so Vincent
kimer um another one
nitzki is not showing right now but he's
on one out of one okay A little
fancy stuff going on here so I'm
beginning to wonder if that game
one was an onp purpose when the bishop
went to H3 instead of
G2 okay it's fully Justified though this
start some space on the queen
side C5 will be the pawn push Knight is
there supporting ready to recapture
keeping this guy watching over
E5 can quickly track down the light
Square
Bishop just being
ketto negative so on a push there is
this Tempo now on the
bishop one of these is going to Flinch
soon
to be careful Queen E2 the bishop gets
squashed with
C4 okay so now it's broken
up Bishop B7 no Knight C6 no E5 has
enough control over it I like Black's
position a real lot Knight C5 seems like
it's going to hunt down the light Square
Bishop Rook C8 Knight C5 E5 challenging
the duo challenging in this
night okay now the only after
challenging the pawn do we have the
peace
Improvement no queen move just yet okay
how to react to this exchange sacrifice
okay didn't even blink on that
one that just came so naturally right
there yeah it is a big pun isn't it in
the center now there's a 2 to one or
excuse me two to zero in the
center completely crushed Queens
side no great discovery after the
captures with this
bishop no bishop move taking
something it's Knight not really doing a
whole lot and there's a problem
here you give up this square if you push
he's giving it up that
square interesting just wants to glue
that Bishop
in always have to watch out for this G2
pawn two
Bishops big
Center how do you make progress here for
White Queen C7 or maybe
F5 thinking F5 F5 it is Queen
G5
maybe put the bishop on
H6 Queen G5 Bishop
H6 maybe keep pushing
pawns okay where we going with the queen
light Square targeting
C3 you could go into an ending Queen C5
exchange Rook C8 going to track down a
bunch of
Pawns this guy can fall eventually but
yeah this King position look at how
beautiful oh nightmare Bishops
King in the
[Music]
center Bishop there first not really
sure what the point of that one
is Bishop G5 in a position to do what
exactly yeah not really sure that
one Bishop G5 is
weird a push you can't take cuz there's
going to be a pin oh and the bishop is
going to be trapped very soon yeah here
this here there's a check and then you
win the bishop he's winning
material it's going to be two two
Bishops versus The Rook oh he has that
square too totally missed that one so I
wonder now is this Rook going to be
trapped forgot about that
square
yeah very clumsy
pieces pass Rook Pawn he's pushing them
all all fourth rank pawns there's a rook
B8 there's a check here I think all pawn
moves are progress here
F4 here
G4 I don't think giving the exchange
back is going to be
helpful could take this Pawn he does
this is
defended he's on C2 now look at the
clock
oh that's rough take another
Pawn now he's keeping the Rook
around he's just looking to
squeeze play it
slow play it
slowly oh you know what if Rook takes I
think there might have been a trick
there that might have been the problem
I think that's what it
was guarding this wants to be able to
recapture these guys are nightmares
completely open this King does not feel
comfortable
check we got the skewer or the
pin resigner here it's a resigner wow
these guys were nightmares really
instructive you know certain go back
here certain moves are instructive to me
just how quick just looking at how quick
they're
played like this right here as soon as
F5 I imagine as soon as Rook C8 it was
already on his mind it's already on his
mind to go for the exchange
sacrifice yeah F5 and then Center just
collapses it's like you get in a
position here as white where it's like
how do you you make
improvements yeah nice game there he is
now on two out of two round
three about 110 players on two out of
two his rating hasn't moved just
realizing those first two wins yeah he's
having a little fun these aren't Mouse
slips he's just looking for something
interesting I
guess oh yeah clear
yeah this impressive like he's at this
all-time high
rating you would think you know you
still tried to extend it and play as
something serious
but
nope some original position I imagine
after three four
moves Center Center's Under
Fire going to reroute this
guy
okay black doesn't want to see kingside
castles he's taking with the queen he's
going to go Queen
side so he's had his fun he early
goinging moves now he's going to play a
bit more serious moves I guess right in
the
center Knight B5 can be a
move Knight B5 with Bishop F4 might have
already been an idea
first things first what's happening here
too many
attackers how to react to this if you
take with the pawn you end up with an
isolated pawn queen takes Queen Pawn
takes Knight takes and then it's forever
Target so the idea here is to meet this
capture with some Knight
B4 but white is there
first I guess with this idea in mind
Queen can't go too far
oh another detail maybe after this then
you start chopping away in the end there
could be a fork on
C7 hitting the king in D
D5 we'll
see Queen here might run into this one
all right Queen is opposite the king
careful
careful as weird as it looks queenside
castles yeah I don't think queenside
Castle is going to happen some something
about it though having the queen
opposite or The Rook opposite the
queen so what's the plan Knight takes
you could take with the
Queen Bishop takes you get the queen in
the end so what's his plan
here did he underestimate that
move
h
okay so he's going to flick in I guess
an in betweener Queen takes Queen he's
going to take there first with
check oh that's nice too now you
exchange and then take here so he's once
more going to be working with the bishop
pair don't know that he's better okay
he's going after this guy if you went to
C3 you're inviting Knight
D5 so take here take here probably take
this guy keep this one
defended still down the pawn needs to
get it back these Rooks are not playing
takes the E Pawn is on The
Rook so on this one he has
defense okay opposite color Bishop
ending oh I didn't missed that that was
even a
move okay that preserves the bishop pair
although we
block
Bishop versus
knight Rook
D7
challenged no feels like it's slightly
better for
white these guys are still potential
targets for this one I think the dark
Square Bishop better than Knight
here ready to exchange and get to an
open
file
time situation oo it's a big factor
approaching 30
seconds okay all base points are covered
here for
black I wonder if this could be an idea
try and rattle this bishop yeah as he's
going for it Rook
D5 B Pawn is
hit double
up this Rook
is
know the greatest piece just cutting off
some King squares
but feel like a white Rook getting
active back here is going to be nice
okay watch out for the tricky
Knight if you exchange these two I think
the chances of a draw are pretty
high
okay try and get to
the the back here two Rooks somehow can
it Target this it's close to maybe
weaving a
mate it's this door
here on the Knight first he can't take
here cuz there's a trick he wants Rook
here okay trade and then Rook here how
you defending
that I think g7's going to
collapse yeah g7's
collapsing that's how he does it pressed
him on the clock as well time ticker in
the end win on time o sets a new record
3364 okay he is now
on three out of three okay round
four how many on three out of three 47
players still on three out of three so
we getting something serious here this
time opponent kuril chevchenko
okay no move yet
D4 ah continuing with
silliness white says I can do that
too all
right serious
move
E6
G5 E6 B5 C5
D5
B5 see any of these pawn moves
G6 B6
B6 kg non a confrontational no Pawn
tension all right there's a little
creativity welcoming an unusual Pawn
structure another Pawn in the center
take a step
up try and fight against E4 does just
that this is no longer a home for a
night can be
kicked Castle's first so now if E4 you
can trade and say in the end ha I have a
two to one in the
center I believe you have to take no no
well no no no no no CU this one you
could still challenge it but I would
expect the capture and don't allow the
alpha zero Pawn so does he want to play
with pawns on
dark
D6 could trade a bunch as well take
twice there and then play D5 Knight
C6 all major is in a minor piece of
piece
position all right D6 it
is can't connect Knights just
yet so what's white considering King
side Queen side castles Queen side
there's already this open file so I
would think you do a same sides
castles see considering a capture and
then Bishop E4 oh aggressive intentions
here
all right so that makes me think he's
he's leaning towards queenside castles
and something on the king's side so now
he's simplifying it a
bit going to put this Knight on a pretty
Square healthy structure for both sides
there is some deficiency on White's end
this
Square uh Knight
F6 into G4
so let's
see no note that black is there just in
time to meet Knight G5 with Knight F6
you don't want to have to meet this move
with
G6 you're asking for H4 so perfect
square for the king Knight imagine yep
H6 two invasive if the pawn is allowed
to get to H6 it punches a hole into the
F6 Square makes G7 fling
lch and the king is forever
uncomfortable Pawn is on if the white
Pawn is on
H6 so how to improve so now yeah if you
go kingside Castle you hang this Pawn
yeah he's still lining
up this idea and he's saying I am
welcome to Queen exchange I'm welcome to
double isolated
pawns kind of interesting cuz can't you
you take and then have these two moves
in there and just freezes these
guys let's see what he's going to go
for
H like this takes A3 there's no pushing
through it's not like this is going to
win
material the Knight could always retake
in the
end you stay defending this
Point okay wow he really in the tank
here he's down to 22 seconds we've seen
this a bunch now Carlson has 2 minutes
and his
opponent's down to like 30 seconds
Knight is under Fire also
A2 how quickly he's pinpointing these so
maybe hops in here targeting this and
stopping the
advance I don't think he car cares too
much about
this is Knight E4 first
or he is taking this Pawn he's saying
you got nothing on the G
file so if you end up taking with the
Rook then the skewer is there The Rook
in the corner is a
goner okay so I'm expecting the Knight
to
capture so the G file remains closed
then
half open for white wait a second okay
so in the
end I mean maybe you could still go in
for the skewer and just don't take after
the sacrifice
here
okay now there is no Queen
A1 okay now he's saying I'm scared yeah
if the Queens come off okay because now
this
is should be completely winning I would
think
what's the pawn count okay he's not so
quick to exchange
Queens you what's wrong with this okay
Knight here you could take and then
there's still a problem with your own
Queen I think you could take here I'm
not seeing Oh okay actually if you take
here there's going to be Knight takes
G6 that's not quite
working going to collect the pawn with
the Knight
defend here just in the nick of time
that's a fancy
maneuver okay there's some checks but no
Rook takes Pawn here Knight F5 in the
end it's on this as
well oh he's collecting
everything he's up a pawn more than a
pawn he's up two pawns everything is
Consolidated one base point to watch
over and there's no time for white as
well start pushing
pawns a lot of ways to approach this no
pressure on this Pawn you could activate
this
Rook defend this guy oh he's trying to
deflect the defense of G
G4 he's okay giving up a
pawn it'd be it'd be an
exchange under 20 seconds
endgame
wizard Rook is stuck
oh what a rough final position Rook
doesn't even have a
square okay that got that got pretty
sharp there on the king side to be
sure
yeah he uh had to go into the tank
there okay he is now on four out of four
round
five and then there were
[Music]
16 on perfect four out of four there's
the
list of
perfects Nakamura and nitzki you're
curious they are currently on three and
a
half okay candidate
Master a serious
start C4 Knight
C3
okay
3365 so he went up another
point that last game he's king and the
weak Square here
E5 very good
setup it's night maneuver to E4 is
always a
thing Knight E2 F4
D3 King in on the E5 Square further on
this capture how is he going to
recapture okay we don't even see
that okay Knight
E2 this is a fancy Bishop
maneuver challenging E5
five B7 is hit change the structure he's
okay taking on doubled B
pawns now on Knight
here wondering about that okay he's not
going with
it once again fighting for
E5 now timing could be an issue I think
A6 B4 and then you move the bishop to
defend The Rook that way B5 isn't to
move if white can get in B5
successfully white is definitely the
better
side so you could try for
this but if that's not working
out you know white gets in this
B5 UND doubles the B pawns okay he's
working on preventing the B5 push so I'm
expecting a bishop move now or okay a
rook move is good as well he's not quite
sure where the bishop belongs meanwhile
this Knight is angling for the A5
Square not easily addressed here okay
have to watch out for unprotected
pieces maybe he still just jumps in here
okay so I actually on Knight
A5 F4 shuts down the bishop
okay does not want the bishop to be shut
down so dark Square Bishop exchange had
this the other day
playing and Blitz
event Bishop takes Pawn takes followed
up with Knight
C5 okay this Pawn is
defended wonder if we're going to have
some exchange sacri or not an exchange
sa sacrifice a peace sacrifice on
A6 yeah okay so here did oh that's a
nice deflection Knight takes you take
here you're on the Rook feels like
dominoes okay now we're getting that
sacrifice I was saying earlier was going
to have a capture a fork these two
points it's just a resigner the whole
Queen side is
collapsing just like
that let me go back for a second here
that was quick
so if you do oh you can't you can't even
take here what am I talking about the
pawn would push through yeah these guys
are just
shattered these two pawns are targeted
by the Rooks the
bishop wow 27 mover did he even go up a
point he went up another
Point
3366 keep setting records okay that puts
him on five out of five round
six
seven players on five out of five
now Grandmaster
opponent all
right another serious
start C4 Knight F3 Knight
C6 oh okay got two Pawns in the center
now take with the D Pawn
no building in the
center still 2 to one now 2 to
zero
yes dark Square Bishop exchange Bishop
on
C4 maybe going to get an ending in the
king arriving on on this Square here
maybe even
E3
overprotecting this point he's saying
you take
me going to take with the
King doesn't care about
castling simplified
enough so now what do we
do there's a counter punch maybe you
rule out okay now now that the Rook is
on the defile he feels a bit more
comfortable The Rook can always come
back over but it does cost a temp
so the Knight is in a way unpinned now
that there's well now it's not all right
if the Knight moved there was a tactic
on
C6 and the story here is what exactly ah
okay so you take here there's this he's
going after the a
pawn yeah this here and if you defend
with that this Pawn Falls and if you go
here you're asking for trouble Knight D2
for
instance so this is ideal um the king is
super cozy on
E3 feels like White's playing with an
extra
piece King is perfect dark
Square nice cover in the center soon
going to be a really active white
Rook so if B5 I mean this Falls Bishop
is hit
Rook A6 a ton of Peace activity maybe
even Bishop takes B5 in some cases all
right so we're going to have Rook takes
C Rook A6 Rook C7 this is a passer now
we have three passers on board Rook C7
it is don't sleep on this check that can
definitely
land I'm thinking thinking this guy's
going to bolt so that this Knight has a
wonderful
Square they fit in really well together
first things first what's black doing
about that pawn all right targets that
one and on Rook
A8 oh look at that Tricky Tricky
Tricky Fork aroni no good night moves by
the way with check or getting in
position to land a fork these guys are I
was going to say too far away there is a
fork Square still but Knight is not in
position yet
so he's up a pawn this is a scary past
Pawn making sure it's not
going too fast too
far more Pawn play on the king side or
can we sneak in these moves yeah he
doesn't want to give this Knight this
Square it's the Knight is boxed out
actually pretty well by the pawns and
the Knight so he just he's just sliding
on
over like is punching a hole into this
Square connected
passers
okay here's the other thing he could
give up a
pawn he might want
to maybe kicks the Knight
away King here King here King
here King B5 first exchange
Knights oh he's taking with the
king Take
here could zigzag your way out this is
defended the whole while black has to
try for
this it's the only chance okay he's
saying you could take a pawn but I don't
want you to take them
consecutively oh that's a nice
move well actually what what's happening
oh King takes you push Rook here you
could play here he has that intersection
Square on E5 look at the time situation
again this 2 minutes versus 30 some
seconds and if the King goes back the
pawn advances so he's going to be able
to put the Rook right
behind yeah The Rook does
everything ideally placed cuts off the
king nothing happening on the king side
he's trying to get this past Pawn
yeah White's there first defending the
pawn has enough time to track this guy
down yeah we're going to have a resigner
here I would
expect or not playing on out of
momentum okay and now a resigner so that
puts him at 6 out of six another plus
one for the r rating
3367 okay round seven the only players
six out of six these two right here
Carlson paired up now
against uh this is Anton
corov let's
see no more
perfects after this
game well there could only be one
perfect after after this game again he's
loving this Rook Pawn Advance One
Step no
pin going to play for some Stonewall
action F5 no F5 Knight
F6 well okay maybe still F5 a quick
knight jump in
there yeah I really wouldn't expect if
Queen
C2 for black to give up the Knight you
play here and then try and glue him
in and try something Wild on the king
side
possibly all right so he's in the
tank G5 it
is Knight is supporting
that Knight takes Knight Pawn takes
Bishop
say covered
twice
okay F6 takes F6 it is it's going to
continue launching pawns I'm
guessing anything exciting happening on
this
diagonal maybe that's what he's thinking
about
okay yes he clearly is thinking about
that Knight takes covers this entry
point Queen check and it comes to a dead
end I think this is winning for
black yeah he's up a piece that move was
missed okay so now up the
piece drives the night away no checks
like covers
it could still go queenside
castles where to put the pieces First
Things
First bishop G7 Queen
F6 uh it's still cozy on the king
side Bishop acts like a pawn and and
still a
bishop yeah kingside castles it is Queen
F6 seems
natural maneuver the
bishop Queen F6 Bishop
D7 Rook d8 Bishop C6 okay
B6 challenging the pawn that's in his
house yeah chipping away at pawns that
are on dark another way to view
it in general a good
Strat playing with the unopposed bishop
ready to chop and then take the
two-point Pawn shut down oh this
bishop having some trouble look how
quick he is
to get this guy
activated also maybe try to hunt this
Pawn he's kicked the bishop off that
diagonal watching over the E4 Square
now super jumpy
Knight
okay drives the Knight away doesn't care
about this Pawn he wants the bishop
pair he wants this Center
Pawn take twice Queen
D5 maybe bishop A6 to here is another
idea right around the corner this queen
is
amazing cannot be
challenged by a knight or a rook anytime
soon 20 seconds we're seeing this time
and time
again
yo just under 30 seconds to 2 plus
Bishop B5 no he's on this guy this one's
a goner this one's been a goner since I
believe Knight takes
E5
wow was he going to go up a point from
this
game watch out for mate there's going to
be a tactic
here watch out for H7 f click that one
in Queen F5 there's a pin
here this is covered let's get out of
the pin Queen
here he's going to sneak
over ah there's the tactic back rank
maters he's ridiculous okay he went a
plus two he's at 3369 now and the only
one at seven out of seven four more to
go wow Hikaru
versus
Carlson this going to be end be the end
of his uh best
rating let's
see 3369 he's still going in with the
silliness wow
okay oh my
goodness you can't get away with this
against
taru too much
okay yeah this isn't a this isn't a good
play Let's
see he's really just having some fun
here crazy
[Music]
3369 A6 B5 Knight C6 Knight
A7
Queen beautiful in the
center so you want to go two with the F
Pawn covering these two points also
Bishop here there's this
one okay so first The Exchange could
consider a
push beautiful
queen now if you play this one how are
you
getting I mean this this
so cramping going to try and weasel out
of it a bishop move Knight C8 Knight
B6
okay or is this another path I'm
thinking the knight at some point has to
play here he's going after the dark
Square
Bishop like doesn't have a huge lead in
development
going to shoot for
this maybe a peace sacrifice on C5 okay
so no dark Square Bishop he get the
Queens
off exchange on E3 and queen E7 is what
I was
thinking it's a trap if you take on B7
Bishop F6 and the queen has no
squares normally you have that one but
not in this
case so he has untangled there's a check
Bishop F5 Knight B6 six he's driving the
Knight away and then Knight here
wow this Pawn up for grabs
okay still a pin here probably a bit
risky taking that
pawn
centralization ready to take can't take
here time to Castle if you're not
castling Knight Knight on
E3
Knight E3 it
is okay and now this with Bishop
A6 or do you work on this guy save this
Pawn space for black space for
white how great of an inconvenience are
these pawns here okay he's targeting the
bishop
first oh after backs off the Knight
here and have a backward Pawn soon now
he's found a
way
crazy after that
beginning okay there's a check you could
insert as well Knight takes Pawn takes
Bishop
check
wow he's going after a
pawn and take here next and then take
here wow he's up a pawn now after that
beginning was not expecting
that not against
taru but it's happening okay there's
this to be
careful he watching over that defend the
pawn bishop here not so fast F7 it's
defending here first Bishop
E6 Bishop B6 it is Rook E4 it's not
really a big
deal maybe continue pushing oh he's
grabbing another
Pawn I don't see any tricks here for
white he going to have to do something
here going have to somehow make this a
passer one
day very active Square for the
queen cozy Bishop position nice and
stable flight Square still needed for
black okay there's only one okay was
going to say one base point there goes
another one the a the a pawn was
vulnerable but this guy is the more
important one don't lose C7 oh that's a
sneaky
move a pin
here Carlson missed that
one so now he's going to have
a tables are turning a bit I think here
so pin here pin
here
what do you
try some D5 move
working possible that you
could take here maybe he's thinking
about
G5 time 30
seconds okay so the plan there was okay
he was threatening to take the bishop
after
unpinning oh wow Rook takes Pawn takes
takes and then Queen
here how's that playing out Queen here
there might be Bishop takes
Pawn takes and then C2 so he's shutting
down the bishop first and now he's going
to go after this point there's a check
though to get out of
it here
okay wow so take the pawn there's a fork
here on
e4
now he's ready to take here but this
Pawn is going to
go Bishop's going to get
here oh okay he was also getting out of
a pin there if the bishop moved there
was Bishop takes on
e4 okay it's feeling like there's going
to be some
Perpetual do not know
yet to go for Perpetual the queen guards
this square there's no
Perpetual okay and where do we go from
here you can't go for a queen exchange
these guys push
through you take here it's going to be
Perpetual yeah Perpetual incoming Pawn
quality one way or the
other a draw after all that wow there
were a ton of pins in that one let me
just go
back so accurate
there going back to right
here I believe I believe like this move
right here was so tempting just tracking
that pawn down I believe this was a
shot maybe but definitely right here if
in this position you come over or you
take the pawn and this position there's
Bishop takes cuz there's a pin on the D
file a lot of pins in that
one so no more perfect after that
one 33 he went down I believe three
points because of that
draw okay he sits now at 6 and a half or
excuse me 7 and A2 out of eight round
number nine playing against nihal sain
lot of hungry players here seven out of
eight eight players at seven out of
eight Carlson 7 and a
half in the
tank I'm expecting a positional battle
ahead but it's going to be dependent on
the start here going with something
silly again silly or
serious
lot of serus he's
giving time
Advantage these are all the serious
moves also G3 maybe
B3 monkey around B4 still no move what's
going on okay best by
test so what's sinin going to play here
G6
okay a fight
ahead wild H
Pawn or
standard spending a lot of time what's
going on
here okay he's ready to go
now Bishop D3
castles not yet saying what he wants to
do with this Pawn have to do something
here okay he's going
oh what is that
about Carlson's just up a
piece what was the intention
there wait a second Let me refresh here
is that actually the board
position it is thought it might have
been some glitch
it just it doesn't make sense let
me I'm I'm just going to stick on the
game I don't know what kind of pre moove
that
was okay well he has an extra Knight
here and he's cool with just simplifying
everything
okay Queen C2 Rook
D1 there's nothing happening here you if
you take on e4 you get an open file but
there's a huge Square then for white
minor
pieces uh Queen A4 C6 Rook D1 Rook B1
grab a pawn take here watch out for the
G Pawn
push and he's going right after the
bishop I mean at this point you could
probably just give up the exchange and
take here he's taking there first
he's getting the Queens off wow okay
quick resigner how many moves was
that 25 mover what what kind of slip was
this in the
beginning okay he was just in pre-move
mode expecting C3 is the only thing I
could
guess he's expecting
C3 meeting C3 with E5
not a good pre
moove especially for an increment
game okay well that puts him oh that
sets a new record by the way too 3370
now all right he is at 8 and a half out
of nine round
10 8 and a half out of nine and three
eight out of
nines
okay let's see if we extend this blitz
record or not
3370 I'm sure he has his ey in
33 I should say
3,400 how's that for a blitz
rating pretty
good okay he's played this Knight C6
move many times times
now he's going with
D6 F7 is a little
sensitive trying to play on the D4
Square Bishop G4 is a
blunder take on F7 Knight G5 okay so
only after the bishop is
secure as he go there Knight's defending
now
E5 move order
details so this was similar to the sain
game sain was expecting C3 and then in
response to that E5 is
fine but we had D5 in the S game still
focusing on the D4 Square the Knight is
now
unpinned ready to take and then crash
through on D4 something's got to give
here not a reliable Defender 1 2 3
attackers and only one
Defender consider a chop a chop and then
defend oh he's going with the Rook
okay interesting you have to give that
guy
up although Bishop Bishop there there's
this this bishop could come back to
F5 simple exchange has a lead in
development Rook nice Rook activity
watch you don't drop this
pawn and takes I would expect Knight
recapture
A5
A5 out of the line of fire also a
battering ram break down the B Point C5
followup looking to UND double take
advantage of a pin something
better what might be better Rook B4 A4
C5 Queen F6 welcoming and
ending and this pwn could be a
problem C5 could draw an arrow okay C5
and now
A4 not taking here there's still a pin
saying work a little harder get out of
the pin before I resolve this
tension there's a pin here as
well okay exchanges now Queen F6 Queen
E7 it
is slightly better structure for
black one isolated
Pawn only one Rook
move and that would drop a pawn okay
diagonal first
thought what could this Knight
do okay this is still a move because
both queens and the Queen on F6 is
unprotected Knight maneuvering in here
might be a
thing I think there's a trick though
Rook takes on B3 would be a
move Queen has a responsibility so now
choose
one Queen
exchange Knight is on a really good
Square king is not in time to come over
here to defend Knight is the most
efficient defender of this point and now
it's major piece
Activity one exchange wild Rook if this
king gets over here going to be a big
problem for team white I
think these Knights still
around any result is still possible King
is cut off time to improve the
[Music]
king I don't know how you improve these
pieces I don't know what magic there is
with the Knight on D4 so time to sneak
the king
over considering a pawn move no staying
cozy over
here going to be a tar Rook is hit this
is going to be a Target
soon so I guess he's he's intending C5
and then Knight D4 he's going after the
weak
link okay no more cutting out the king
he wants to stay trained here doesn't
want to see these guys get
rolling okay some mating Nets
maybe possible Pawn on
H4 maybe Knight on G3 the king is on the
back rank it's not allowing that H4
takes takes F4 this Knight post will be
challenged H so this could be a Target
very soon both Knights defending very
important pawns he's going after this
guy and after King G2 where's The Rook
going
imagine here looking for a check next
and then
this it's going to get still tactical
time is going to be a big factor okay
interesting Pawn
Advance maybe
go no not
taking so now check first and then take
and The Rook could be trapped like if
you take here this then you have to give
up a pawn right back giving the check
first he's not I don't think he's going
to take here
yeah he's keeping the king he's saying
there's value in just keeping the king
sealed to the first rank it's cut off so
now how to find a way in with the King
you could see some
mates how to create a hole here for the
king Knight is so tricky watch out for
the
fork
time time is going to be a big factor
wow so sneaky he's getting this
two-point Pawn these guys are going to
be split and the King has a path
up wow another check Knight here he's
going to try and get the other Pawn you
can see all of these guys
falling wow take now he's going to be
running the check he's doesn't matter he
could insert the check
first the king can't play here he's able
to push through the Knight out of
position this one's
over wow was he going to go up one
point it's over you could take the
Knight actually you couldn't take the
Knight just there we had a
resigner yeah
taking right here
yeah both would be
queening okay that right there sets
another record he is at
3372 with one round to go incredible all
right final
round Bortnick has eight and a
half Carlson n and a half aaro
nine let's see a win here and he takes
the early
titled
Tuesday all kinds
defense
okay stopping Bishop
F5 how does this guy get
deployed no G4 no
F5 Queen
exchange and Bishop G4 there's F3 Bishop
H5 E6 has a pawn
sacrifice Drive the Knight away A3
Knight D5 C4 Knight
C3 or do you try C4 first and then
A3 Knight A3 not on my
radar
okay now he's going to give him a kick
play
F4
where's the Knight go okay I don't think
you want to take twice I don't know you
you win a pawn but the bishop pair does
count for something he is going to go
for oh he's not going for that let's
just Safeguard this guy he's saying if
you defend with the pawn I'm going to
try and play against your light Square
Bishop Knight B Knight B5 Knight D4 A4
A5 Knight slow moves to
improve Bishop B6 defends the pawn but
it's very very awkward
Knight B5 Knight C7
D4 a draw is just agreed upon
wow
okay
so that puts him at 10 out of 11 a draw
really okay a sudden end there
uneventful so that puts him at 10 out of
11 there it is
is 10 9 and 1 12 9 1 2 3 Carlson
Nakamura
and kovalev taking third
there all right um Feel Free as usual to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below hope you enjoyed
it and maybe took a thing or two away
feel free to share what game you thought
was uh most
interesting that's all for now
take care
bye